avoided a technical recession but still
pretty much flat what's the reaction to
these revised figures well these figures
show there is underlying resilience in
the UK economy which is obviously a good
thing but we should also remember that
families up and down the country are
facing real pressure which is why we
introduced a windfall tax which means
that about half the bill of the average
family is being paid a total of three
thousand pounds of support and the root
cause of this pressure is something that
hasn't changed today which is inflation
is still more than 10 and that's why we
will continue to take the difficult
decisions necessary to bring down
inflation caused by what's happened in
Ukraine that is the way we will get back
to Healthy Growth and relieve the
pressure on families